y aquí está la reacción general para
formar este eres de nitrato a partir de
alcoholes tenemos nuestro alcohol del
lado izquierdo y lo hacemos reaccionar
con ácido nítrico concentrado y ácido
sulfúrico concentrado como nuestro
catalizador y me parece que esta
reacción es reversible
así que pondré esta flecha formaríamos
nuestro esther de nitrato aquí del lado
derecho también podemos formar agua en
el proceso y la molécula de agua va a
provenir de este hidrógeno del alcohol y
este
en nuestro ácido nítrico
veamos el mecanismo para formar este
eres de nitrato
voy a empezar por volver a dibujar
nuestra molécula de ácido nítrico aquí
me parece que este es el mecanismo
correcto aunque intente buscar los
mecanismos en algunos libros de texto no
pude encontrar este mecanismo en ningún
lado entonces espero que el que voy a
mostrarles sea el correcto
muy bien entonces si pienso en ácido
nítrico y ácido sulfúrico el ácido
sulfúrico es el ácido más fuerte por lo
que el ácido sulfúrico va a donar
protones y el ácido nítrico va a aceptar
estos protones el ácido nítrico va a
funcionar como una base
entonces un par de electrones
disponibles del oxígeno van a tomar este
protón y ahora el oxígeno va a tener
tres enlaces dos unidos a hidrógenos y
uno que siguió unido a este nitrógeno
sigue teniendo un par de electrones lo
que le dará una carga formal de más 1
este nitrógeno de aquí sigue estando
doblemente unido a un oxígeno
sigue unido a este oxígeno de aquí una
carga formal de menos
y una carga formal de más 1 así este es
el primer paso de nuestro mecanismo de
reacción ha sido base
en el siguiente paso si vemos
detenidamente podemos ver que tenemos
agua como nuestro grupo saliente y un
par de electrones disponibles en nuestro
oxígeno se mueven para acá para formar
un nuevo enlace pi eso puede mover estos
electrones de aquí hacia el oxígeno y el
agua ya se fue vamos a dibujar el
resultado de esto ahora tenemos h2o como
grupo saliente h2o se fue
tenemos el nitrógeno que tenía un doble
enlace a un oxígeno aquí arriba y ahora
también tiene un doble enlace con otro
oxígeno aquí abajo y sigue teniendo una
carga formal de más 1
a esto se le llama jon y trono y dado
que el nitrógeno tiene carga positiva
quiere electrones por lo que va a
funcionar como un electro filo en el
siguiente paso del mecanismo cuando hay
una molécula de alcohol los alcoholes
tienen pares de electrones
sabemos que esos electrones con carga
negativa pueden funcionar como núcleo
filos entonces el electrón con carga
negativa es atraído al nitrógeno con
carga positiva el ataque en núcleo
físico va a lanzar estos electrones al
oxígeno y vamos a dibujar el producto de
este ataque núcleo físico
bien
ahora tenemos nuestro grupo r unido a un
oxígeno
y nuestro oxígeno está ahora unido a
este nitrógeno de aquí este oxígeno
también está unido a un hidrógeno
dándole una carga formal de más 1 y
nuestro nitrógeno sigue teniendo un
doble enlace al oxígeno de arriba y
ahora tiene un enlace sencillo a este
oxígeno dándole una carga formal de
menos 1 y dándole a este nitrógeno una
carga formal de más 1
entonces ya casi hemos formado nuestro
esther de nitrato si vemos aquí todo lo
que tenemos que hacer ahora es una
reacción ha sido base para quitar este
protón de nuestro oxígeno el agua es una
base bastante decente
un par de electrones disponibles en
nuestro oxígeno pueden tomar este protón
dejando estos electrones atrás en el
oxígeno de aquí y estaríamos formando
nuestro
esther de nitrato entonces ahora tenemos
r con un oxígeno y luego no2 así
nuevamente creo que este es el mecanismo
correcto pero no estoy 100% segura
la formación de ésteres de nitrato tiene
unos pocos pero muy famosos ejemplos
veamos la reacción más famosa en la que
se forma un esther de nitrato
veamos qué pasa si empezamos con este
alcohol
como nuestro reactivo
este es llamado glycerol officer ina y
tiene tres grupos h y se hace reaccionar
glicerina con un exceso de ácido nítrico
ácido sulfúrico
ambos concentrados formaríamos un esther
de nitrato en cada uno de nuestros
grupos o h entonces vamos a formar un
esther de nitrato en cada uno de
nuestros grupos o h para obtener esta
molécula como producto colocamos grupos
nitro en la glicerina obteniendo
nitroglicerina por supuesto todos saben
acerca de la nitroglicerina es un
explosivo muy famoso es un líquido es
extremadamente sensible a conmociones
por lo que es extremadamente peligrosa
la nitroglicerina es algo que nadie debe
de intentar hacer en casa por lo que no
es una buena demostración para
profesores de química
una mejor demostración para profesores
de química sería formar otro esther de
nitrato comenzando con algodón o
celulosa aquí tenemos el polímero de
luminosa
y está compuesta de muchas moléculas de
glucosa
esta es una molécula de glucosa y esta
es una molécula de glucosa también y si
juntas muchas de estas moléculas de
glucosa en un polímero gigante obtiene
celulosa conocida también como algodón
si tomas un montón de bolas de algodón y
las mezclas con ácido nítrico
concentrado y ácido sulfúrico
concentrado puedes colocar grupos nitro
en cada uno de estos grupos alcohol
podrías formar este desde nitrato cada
uno de estos grupos alcohol se
convierten en un esther de nitrato voy a
poner mis esther este nitrato en la
molécula
3 esther es de nitrato por cada molécula
de glucosa
y formaremos nitrato de celulosa como
producto también conocido como algodón
pólvora el algodón pólvora es mucho más
estable que la nitroglicerina puedes
almacenar algodón pólvora durante la
noche y si lo enciendes obtendrás una
pequeña bola de fuego por lo que es una
excelente demostración para estudiantes
de química